hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round nine of
2021 tata steel chess masters uh it's
anish giri versus radulla voitershek
and we have a very exciting game
featuring none other than the london
system
and something i wanted to mention uh is
that everybody is playing the london
system today doesn't matter if you're
just a beginner or if you're a grand
master
uh even magnus crossing used it in the
world chess championship in the world
blitz championship
against a few a few opponents and even
defeated vladimir kramnik with the
london system so
everyone uses it and it's very hard to
even play chess
if you don't know a thing or two about
how to counter it
and i've had terrible experiences
playing against the london system so
for the past few days i've been working
on a very nice tutorial on how to
counter the london system uh
in the simplest possible way so if any
of you guys are interested in that i
will also
uh post a video maybe maybe even
tomorrow tomorrow's a rest day at the
tata still
so maybe tomorrow but if not then after
uh the tournament because i've had
enough of
losing all the games to white with when
they play the london system
so if you are also like that you might
enjoy
learning a thing or two about how to
counter it but in this game
uh of course this is the london system
at the absolute highest level so let's
see what happens here so gary
uh with the white pieces opens with d4
uh we have knight to f6 we have bishop
to f4 d5 and
now e3 i'm going for the london system
set up
voyager strikes in the center with c5
and now
knight to f3 so this has all been played
before nothing new for the moment
knight to c6 and knight b to d2
preparing to
develop this pawn to c3 to strengthen
the center bishop to g4
and now c3 as planned with e6
and now queen to b3 uh putting pressure
on the b7 pawn so queen to c8
and now h3 asking do you want to capture
or go back with the bishop
you don't really gain anything by
capturing here so bishop back to h5
and now bishop to e2 we have bishop to
e7 black prepares the castle
and now both players just castle castles
castles
and here there are a few games where
rook f2 e1 was played but gary just goes
back with the queen he plays queen to d1
and now we have a completely new game
already as of move 11. what's the idea
behind queen to d1
gary wants to capture uh on c5 and then
advance the pawn
to b4 and then uh strengthen the
position with a3 or maybe even a4
so let's see what happens here we have
knight to d7
uh and now rook to e1 we have queen to
d8 now
no longer is the queen needed on c8 as
the b7 pawn is not under attack
and here geary captures we have d
captures on c5 erratic
recaptures with the knight knight
captures on c5 and now
b4 uh pushing the knight back knight
back to d7
and now a3 just uh strengthening this
setup here
we have knight to b6 as now the c4
square has been somewhat weakened
uh and now rook to c1 uh by geary we
have
f6 now uh increasing the pressure in the
center now even uh e5 might be an idea
uh so giri goes for e4 and now e5
pushing this bishop back
have bishop to e3 and now bishop back to
f7
uh defending the d5 pawn but now gary
finds a very nice
very nice idea on how to grab some sort
of a positional advantage with bishop
captures and b6
usually you don't want to give up a
bishop for a knight if it's an open game
but here
geary finds compensation with a captures
on b6
e captures on d5 bishop captures and now
a4 so here
gary kind of ruined the black spawn
structure here and he does have a very
nice
pawn storm coming here on the queen side
and here
uh we have f5 and f5 is a very
interesting move uh point being
that black needs a move here and it's
very hard to find one
uh you could just go for the weighting
move bishop to e6 or you could try
uh the immediate aggressive e4 but e4
requires uh
well uh it doesn't really work just yet
because the knight can capture and if a
knight captures bishop captures
you have this bishop to see for check
with an attack on the bishop and after
the king moves you can just capture here
let's say captures captures and white
will always be better here if you
try and recapture upon rook to d7 is
coming and then
white is just winning there's too much
pressure here uh if
b5 comes then you will just lose the
bishop so you'd have to play something
like bishop here
but then rook to f7 and this is just the
beautiful for white
if captures then of course this leads to
checkmate so you have to go to some
silly square like g8 and then you can
play rook captures on b7 start
collecting the rook is under attack
and it's just a pretty overwhelming
position for black to handle
so here instead after a4 we have f5 by
voit and now preparing e4 but this
also means that the e5 pawn is no longer
defended so
b5 does make sense to remove the
defender of this pawn and this is
exactly what gary plays he plays b5
uh we have e for now if you just move
the knight the knight captures and e5 is
great for white so e4
this was the plan behind f5 uh b
captures on c6 e captures an e
on f3 bishop captures with b captures
and c6
bishop captures on the e5 and the c
captures on the e5 so a little bit of a
capture fest going on there
and not knight to f3 and now when you
look at everything
that has happened uh the position is
quite
equalish with the material being
absolutely equal and it's a bishop
against
knight uh so let's see what what's
happening here we have bishop to f6
preparing to put some pressure on this
pawn and now rook to e6
gear is now preparing queen to b3 to put
some pressure on that b6 pawn
we have king to h8 getting the king to
a little bit of a safer square and now
uh queen to b3
going after the pawn and now queen to d7
again with a double attack on the a4
pawn here
so rook captures on b6 and now not queen
captures an a5 if you go for this trade
then everything just gets traded off
captures captures and captures
so not much for you to look for there so
instead
rook captures on a4 was played uh and
now comes uh
rook to d1 shifting attention to the d5
pawn
and now rook a back to a8 uh we
rook captures on d5 and now queen to c7
uh with
a double attack on the c3 pawn uh and
now
uh it's also very dangerous it's not
just that the c3 pawn is under attack
but also
uh the queen from c7 covers the h2
square so you have to be careful if rook
to a1 check comes what's happening
will you be losing material will you be
blundering the game
uh so here gary immediately takes care
of that by playing
g3 uh just uh blocking this diagonal all
together and creating some breeding
square uh breathing room for the king
and g2
uh queen captures on c3 queen captures
and
now bishop captures on c3 uh we have h4
uh and now king to g8 uh radik also
starts bringing the king into the game
rook to b7 and now rook eight to d8
trying to get uh get a pair of roofs
traded off the board so rook to c5
attacking the bishop and now rook the c8
we have brooke to d5
and radik now happy to repeat rook to
the e8 we have rook d
to b5 geary declines the repetition and
he still
uh wants to play as there is there is
still poison in the position
uh even though even if you had the
double rooks uh on the
okay not not like that but let's say if
even if you double rooks the g7 pawn
will always be guarded by this bishop so
it's very
uh difficult to break through but if you
play something like h5 h6 and kind of
weaken
this pawn then if g6 then the h7 pawn
becomes
vulnerable and so on so this is what
gear is planning but it's
very hard to get there so here rook to
d6
and rook to c7 now attacks the bishop
bishop goes to a1 and now
king to g2 just improving the position
of the king
rook back to a6 and now h5
and here we have rook to a2 problem is
if you play a move like h6 to prevent
the white from pushing h6
then knight to h4 to g6 will be very
annoying for black
so instead after h5 we have rook to a2
now putting some pressure on that f2
pawn uh for example if
you allow black black might push f4 try
to open up the position here open up
this rook and then it could be very
dangerous
so here we have rook to d5 going h6
right away can be met with the g
captures on h6 so
it's not much for white if rook beat the
b7
then you can just play rook to a6 and
now after this pawn is captured
just f4 and black is very happy you're
never doing anything
along this g7 square and the h6 pawn is
covered
so black would be very happy here so
instead after rook to a2 we have rook to
d5
and now comes rook back to a6 keeping an
eye on that
h6 square knights the h for now
uh so what do you play here the f5 pawn
is under attack uh voyager defends it
with the g6 and now
this is how giri gets his pawn to h6 of
course he doesn't capture here it's
defended twice not really anything to be
gained from it
so h6 and now gary will uh double up
the rooks here and try to uh create some
pressure along the
uh along the seventh rank and this was
gary's plan all along he was trying to
get that h pawn up the board
he was able to do it and now there
definitely are some chances and tricks
in the position
so radik uh continues to push his f pawn
as this is the only serious counter play
black has
and gary of course doesn't want to allow
opening up of the of the f file so g4
with f3 with check and now king to g3
even though the f1 can be captured
uh you can never gain anything from it
for example if
knight captures here then there's the
very tricky rook k4
kind of going after this pawn and if you
defend the pawn then just to rook a3
and the knight is lost there is no way
to defend it
so there are tricks and there's no need
to capture the pawn right away if you'll
need it later on you can capture it
later on so
king to g3 by geary and now rook to b6
uh by
by voitech we have rook c to d7 now
double
uh sorry rook c to the seven doubling
rooks on the d
file and now comes rook to b3
uh here just defending that pawn even
though there's no reason
to capture it just yet giri now pushes
g5
and by pushing g5 geary also sets a
deadly trap because now the h6 pawn is
defended
and there is a lot of poison in the
position so here
rook to b4 is uh one of one resilient
way for black to continue playing this
but it's also extremely hard
not just to find this move but also to
uh try
try and make use of it the problem is uh
here
black played bishop to b2 and the
position is now completely winning for
geary
so uh feel free to pause the video and
win the uh
win the position for geary so he can
take the sole lead in the tournament
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
winning this game for giri and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
bishop captures uh on h7 uh and after
bishop captures an h7 was played it was
in this position on mu 49 that arado
slavoitashik resigned the game
and another great victory for anishigiri
who takes soul
lead in this tournament we're not going
to show the standings just yet as i plan
to show
at least one more game from uh from
round nine and then we're going to
discuss the standings but
just so you know gary is now the sole
leader of the tournament
problem is you cannot capture the rook
if you captured the rook we said the h6
pawn is defended
now comes rook d7 check and there's no
way to defend whatever you play
let's say you go here it's just knight
captures a way to check king to g8 and
now
h7 with checkmate so everything is
covered here
uh nowhere for the black king to go and
even if you don't capture this rook
uh there's no good move here uh
like you could try rook to f7 but it
still
just loses terribly for example captures
captures rook d7 check
king that e6 goes after the rook now
just rook d8 you cover the queening
square
and h7 and h8 will win the game of
course
there are no tricks let's say bishop e5
checking g4 rook before check you're
gonna go king to h3
and now there's nothing to be done here
rook b7
to cover this square but just rookie
check
and now you have to guard uh the bishop
wherever you go king d6 knight captures
here
and now it's just two connected past
pawns of course completely
completely winning uh for uh for white
so after real captures on h7
uh uh wojciech resigned and a brilliant
victory for anishigiri
and will this be his first year to win
the tata steel
uh the tata still masters we'll see as
there are three more rounds to go
and in next round which is not tomorrow
it's on friday
uh giri faces none other than world
champion magnus carlsen his nemesis
and we'll see what happens in that game
gary will have the black pieces
so uh we'll see everyone's been talking
about gary snyder
uh and if magnus goes for e4 will be
very interesting to see
how how magnus will deal with that but i
don't know if he's going to go for e4
but he might so hopefully we get a we
get a we get a very crazy game
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh
if you hate the london uh then you know
wait for a few more days and i will
save you all from from this uh terrible
position you're in
uh i would like to thank gerald lad ali
assad sulfur uh matthew carr bernard
omrani and andrew manjian for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
steel checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day